Jack wrote in saying hey is there
something in movies that's always
depicted incorrectly that really bothers
you yes absolutely one of the things is
hacking when you see hacking in movies
I'll bring my keyboard over the the the
the shot will dramatically cut to the
hacker and then you see this as just
this hyper-fast constant tapping on the
keyboard as if that's how hacking
actually works it happened so quickly
without having to sort of like think
about what's going on that one bothers
me the explosions also bother me were
any small uh gasoline leak or whatever
leads to this catastrophic fireball
explosion the the gunplay stuff right
that the sound effects of the cocking of
guns that also often is is not the way
it would be in real life those are a few
i can think of how about in action
movies when there's like some sort of
fighting scenario and one here has to
take on like 10 enemies and they're all
just a bunch of doofuses and try to
fight them one at a time yeah and they
never seem to win there's so many that
you could go I mean number one it's the
idea of one guy defeating 20 or 30
people that are trying to stop him
sometimes they're armed whatever right
that it's 20 or 30 people the other is
just how quickly everybody either dies
or gets knocked out from like a single
punch or or whatever just instantly it's
like people are going down like you're
hitting hitting flies with a fly swatter
one at a time and they stay down and
they stay down right uh and also the and
I know you have to sort of suspend
disbelief in in a lot of movies but the
idea that there's murders and and crimes
committed to move the plot along and
just like police are totally incompetent
they never catch up with the perpetrator
people are killed in the progress in in
the course of a movie and it's never
really explained like how how that the
fact that there's a serial murderer who
is just killing person after person in
the progress of the of the film uh in
the course of the film and they just
never get caught it's never addressed
and I know you're supposed to just go
with it right it's a fantasy but that is
pretty tough for me yeah you have to put
your rationale
I decide if you have any shot at
whatsoever at enjoying the movie yeah
send me your thoughts are there any in
particular in movies any ideas and
movies that bother you I'm trying to
think if there are at any others uh the
sometimes you will see that someone is
running out of a building and they'll
pull the fire alarm and instantly the
sprinklers go off and the entire
building is covered in water number one
typically pulling a fire alarm will not
set off sprinklers and number two most
sprinkler systems are sophisticated
enough that you're not going to soak the
entire building when a sprinkler goes
off it'll either be one office like our
sprinkler system here if it went off
here uh the next office over is not
going all of a sudden be soaked in water
never mind the entire building and also
sometimes when you pull the the fire
alarm the UM the the lights go out in
the entire building and that generally
also doesn't happen you just sort of
needed to move the plot along yeah that
one's pretty laughable and it seems as
if all these tasks get completed with
exactly the amount of time they needed
no doubt about it yeah whether it's
three minutes or 20 minutes to disarm a
bomb you can count on having two seconds
left when it's ultimately uh disarmed
most of these things apply to sort of
like action movies I think no doubt send
me some of your favorite annoying movie
a situations tropes whatever that you
don't like